famer anthony munoz knows about
protection as he was one of the greatest
offensive linemen in league history
keeping quarterbacks from getting sacked
bianca holman shows us how he's now
working to promote protection
from the coronavirus
almost 40 percent of nevada and 16 or
older have at least one shot of the
coven 19 vaccine
and yes things are progressing health
officials want to speed things up and
they're enlisting the help of star
athletes matter of fact a former nfl
star player and current hall of famer
came to visit unlv right here to
encourage
young adults to get the kovit 19 shot
the former star player from the bengals
and the buccaneers spoke with rebel
students and staff in the student center
the silver summit health plan and pro
football hall of fame launched a
campaign to educate people about the
safety
and importance of the vaccine especially
communities of color
it's a focus for the university as well
with coveted prevention methods in place
all across campus but they also have a
vaccination site
making the shop more accessible to
people i've had both my shots
you know and they say what'd you do i
said well you know i played a lot of
years of sports and
when i got hurt i didn't try and do
things on my own i listened to the
medical staff i got advice because
they're the trained ones and it's no
different now going through pandemic
muno also says it's important to thank
our front line workers and our health
care staff
who've worked tirelessly this past year
keeping us safe and more visits are
planned throughout the day
he also plans to stop at bellagio a
college preparatory school and also
red rock bianca holman 8 news now